Northern Ireland and the president's
very keen to see the institutions up and
running again in Northern Ireland and
hopefully see the Windsor framework uh
fully put into operation talked about
economic cooperation as well
um agreed to cooperate closely on cyber
security which is important for both of
us
um as countries and spoke about the
potential visit he certainly hopes and
expects to come to Ireland hopefully in
the future and be very much a homecoming
visit as well as an official
um official visit as well so
not at this stage but um very much hopes
and expects to come to Ireland and we
look forward to rolling out the red carp
when that comes so thanks very much
um well I think that's that's probably a
separate issue but you know he's hugely
informed and very much across what's
happening in Ireland and very supportive
of our efforts and would like to see the
Good Friday agreement operating as we
should thanks for that thank you
[Music]
still have enough for him he was
standing
foreign